[Music]
mythology and folklore are two things
often mentioned in tandem and though in
some cases they are very similar they
aren't the exact same so what is the
difference between folklore and
mythology in order for us to
differentiate between the two we first
have to really understand what makes
them so similar at their very core both
mythology and folklore in basic terms
are a form of storytelling perhaps the
most ancient forms of narrative we have
available to us today you can consider
folklore a subset or a branch of
mythology and even vice versa depending
on who you're asking but more often than
not it does feel like folklore is the
small fish in the much bigger pond that
is mythology where the difference
between them can really be seen is
within the stories themselves and what
they attempt to explain to us
mythology often derives from what many
consider to be sacred texts it aims to
tell us about the time before we existed
how we and everything around us were
created these stories were often held as
the truth and so they became part of
many people's religion they discussed
deities and supernatural figures that
they believed to be involved in our
creation at a time when our scientific
knowledge was very limited these stories
provided explanations to things that
we've only really began to understand
when these religion has lost their
following or when they were absorbed
into others they began to be referred to
as mythology so even today is most
practice religions in a couple thousand
years from now could be seen as not much
more than just stories of mythology
we're folklore differs the most famous
ology is in time and scale mythology
clearly focuses on the beginning of time
the explanation of civilization and
culture whereas the creatures spirits
and deities of folklore almost just
exist without this need for a religious
or cosmic connection folk tales are told
on a much smaller scale and often tend
to be exclusive to a specific village in
town or city they do at times include
gods and goddesses in their stories but
they often do so over specific meaning
or moral in mind that doesn't solely
refer back to creation or divinity the
way in which tales of mythology and
folklore travelled was naturally quite
similar because at the time they didn't
have things like printing houses and
education wasn't as widely available as
it is today meaning many people just
couldn't read or write a select few
poets and writers would eventually
document these stories hence why we know
so much about certain mythologies on a
global scale although some folklore was
documented in poems and various stories
it remained a more oral form of
storytelling a legend that you might
have heard of about a witch or some kind
of monster
might be quite different or even
remarkably similar to one on the other
side of the globe and it's likely that
you'll never know because many of these
folktales are passed down through songs
and dances we will have that one story
or legend local to our town or city
Japan is quite a good example of a
country that has a large amount of
mythology and folklore that coexist it
has its to establish religions of Shinto
and Buddhism where we get these tales of
deities and kami that attempt to explain
japan's creation but it also has a vast
amount of creatures and cryptids that
tie into much more local folklore so to
summarise mythology and folklore are
quite similar in terms of storytelling
but the main difference is an intention
what they aim to explain one attempts to
explain the universe to us and the other
is a much smaller scale of storytelling
that focuses on specific areas and
individuals hopefully you found that
explanation somewhat helpful
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained